tonight a fox news exclusive we greet an
afghan combat translator and his family
as they arrive
in the u.s this comes as thousands of
other interpreters
desperately seek visas to leave
afghanistan before the last u.s troops
are gone
and the taliban comes to hunt them down
national security correspondent jennifer
griffin has the story tonight
military veterans from the american
legion and no one left behind
waited for three hours at dulles
international airport outside washington
dc
to greet this afghan combat translator
who risked his life for the u.s
military for years and finally received
his special immigrant visa to the u.s
on may 27th as u.s troops hastened their
withdrawal
fearful the taliban will target his
family back in afghanistan
he asked that we refer to him by a
pseudonym we'll call him sadiq
although it was a long journey for us
the visa process took a long
time like three and a half years but
finally
they made it how do you feel now that
you're here
uh i'm feel safe you know
i'm i feel really good because
i survived from many threats and then
there was sam an iraqi translator who
became the state department's first
special immigrant visa recipient in 2006
and now serves in the u.s air force he
came to welcome sadiq and his family to
america
i was in their shoes one day over 15
years ago
and i i really appreciated the fact that
i was welcomed by a lot of people and
those who
made me feel that this is my my home now
sam testified in 2007 about the dangers
faced by those working with the u.s
military
senator ted kennedy took up his case and
the special immigrant visa program was
born
i honestly believe that would be killed
my name was listed on the doors of
several mosques
calling for my death for sadiq who
arrived with his wife and four children
for a new life in the u.s
sponsored by the non-profit keeping our
promise rochester
his fortune is bittersweet are you
worried about
those who are waiting in afghanistan of
course of course
we hope that they should not get forgot
and they should get fully supported and
they should receive their visa like me
and they should come to the united
states
and start a better life what will happen
if the u.s doesn't bring them here
the bad guys will find them and they
will
kill them i've seen this scenario in
iraq and i i would hate to see it
happen again in afghanistan they would
more most
certainly be targeted by a taliban and
killed
as a result u.s officials say there is
no plan to evacuate these afghan
translators
evacuation is the wrong word we're
determined to make good on our
obligation to those who helped us
but the u.s embassy visa section is
closed for interviews due to covid
lawmakers are demanding president biden
act if he doesn't act
and he doesn't get these people out
blood will be on his hands
and on his administration's hands there
is a moral imperative at play here
the american handshake has to mean
something
eighteen thousand afghans who risk their
lives for the u.s
are still waiting at dulles airport
jennifer griffin fox news
we'll continue to follow that story hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else